hey guys Ryan right here I literally
hopped out of the shower and I got blown
up with comments the [ __ ] new Star
Wars trailer is out ah I am so [ __ ]
stoked heartbeats raisin
ah force is strong in my family
my father has it
or - I have it my sister hasn't
you have that power too
last Christmas present
Chuey
ha I can't [ __ ] it away oh my god oh my
god let's watch it again yeah I [ __ ]
look look
love the shot [ __ ] love the shot man
it's a [ __ ] beautiful shot
- you guys are the best for telling me
this about forces stone in my family
love the maker
I had damaged his dark imagery is so
good
my sister acid
you have that power too
I got so many chills
Wow Wow chewy for all and I love that I
love that what a great tease
chewie we're all its [ __ ] Chewbacca
and Han Solo man oh god I know I just
got out of shower but now I'm like
sweating balls here man
oh Jesus damn you know like the first
trailer was good enough for me this
trailer I loved every moment of it I
love this story that they're hinting at
with the legacy of Jedi's the
destruction and mayhem looks awesome you
do get that JJ Abrams touch but it's not
too much JJ Abrams that it's taking away
from Star Wars it's adding to it one
thing I love about this trailer is that
it's not just about spectacle like
they're really communicating strong
emotion to you that Darth Vader mask all
destroyed and stuff just this is the
Star Wars we've needed for a long time
you can just tell it's gonna [ __ ]
rock I don't care man sometimes I get so
excited that people think I'm mentally
challenged I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
if you think I'm like [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] you
this looks [ __ ] amazing just the
little bits I don't know who that
actresses that they keep showing she's
[ __ ] hot I could totally watch this
movie just because the hot she is
there's a lot of new imagery there's a
lot of omage to old imagery like the
[ __ ] war continues but damn that last
shot at Han Solo and Chewie it's like
anyway guys thanks so much for telling
me that was out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where I'm
constantly posting pictures on my left
scrotum
rich see tennis hey Ryan it's my 21st
birthday can I get a shout out in your
next video your channel is awesome and
deserves 1 million subscribers 1 billion
subscribers
Tyrone Magnus yeah richie tennis dude
21st birthday good for you
you know what that means right your ass
is gonna get drunk and then you're gonna
snort some cocaine smoke some weed to
balance it out then you need to take
some ecstasy and trip out and then
you're going to take some heroin and
you're gonna go to sleep but then you're
going to wake up and take some adderall
60 milligrams so you're going to be
focused and then afterwards you're going
to go to a strip club and pay $600 to
get blown by a stripper I met someone
who actually did that you're going to be
the next person